Welcome to our last Office Hours.
This is basically just kind of a wrap up and any last questions that we saw
that we felt needed to be answered before we ended the course. Right? >>Yep, yep.
Okay. Let's just jump right in.
First question was if you were building
Reddit or Hipmunk today,
would you build it on Google App Engine or
would you go ahead and--
That's a really good question, and
the short answer is: I'm not sure.
I think we could build Reddit or Hipmunk on
Google App Engine.
Probably definitely Hipmunk, a site that I know is--because it's a travel site--
it's never going to be at the scale that Reddit is,
because even the biggest travel sites aren't anywhere near the scale that Reddit is.
Yeah, so I would have no problem doing that.
Now, Reddit--it's funny, because when I started Reddit we didn't expect it to be a big site.
I was actually--my level of knowledge was less than where yours is now.
App Engine would have saved us a lot of heartache.
Now, for the scale that Reddit is now, I don't know if App Engine would work.
Because it's at such a large scale we need to have control over a lot of little pieces,
but I think for the first couple of years of Reddit's life absolutely it would've worked just fine.
Over Reddit's existence, we've rewritten it
probably 5 or 6 times
and moved a couple data centers and we moved from our own machines
to our first data center to now we're on
Amazon Web Services.
Each of those was a pretty major
architecture change.
I imagine we'd consider starting the App Engine
and then probably migrate to our own more custom setup down the road.